my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny
just a scattering of drive-bys and i
live
in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work
at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a goldfish there's
something inside you guys i want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that
put these on okay fine oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something guy
there is no easy way to say this this
world it's a video game
you're not real please
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time now if that's not real
i don't know what it is i know this
world is just a game but this place
these people that's all i have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy next
guy i'm gonna be the great guy well
enjoy your lifetime supply of virginity
off you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before i really wish you'd
mentioned that
yeah why
[Music]
that actually hurt my hands we can save
our world
but we have to fight
right together but i love it
time's up
i can't die
[Music]
you